Source but not all of or the
collection mentioned with regards to the
prophet Muhammad's Miracles Sall
alai are more indepthly
mentioned
in and so we wanted to take a few
classes and mention all of
these Miracles that the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam was recorded
to have
performed we
discussed previously the Quran the book
of Allah the ultimate of
Miracles after
that
[Silence]
the
first or the second I should say miracle
that the prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam it's mentioned here by the
noi that he performed was the splitting
of the Moon and when we say performed
what we mean is that Allah subhanahu
waala that Allah subhanahu
waala caused
this Miracle to occur because of him
or for
him and so the splitting of the moon is
something that
occurred in the mecca period the mecan
era prior to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
wasallam Hijra and migration to
Medina and this is something that the
scholars and the
companions all agree upon that this is
something that
occurred
some of the later
generations of
mu very
few had mentioned that
[Silence]
for
the
[Silence]
for
just wanted to clarify the issue of the
splitting of the
Moon
some
have some have
attempted to
deny that this is something that
occurred in the time of the Prophet s.
wasam splitting of the
moon and the reason for
that is that we don't find this
mentioned or
documented by other historians outside
of the Arabic Arab
peninsula we have this in the Quran it's
mentioned
in the Sunnah bukari and Muslim major
books of
Hadith mentioned and many companions
mentioned it mentioned it the
generations that followed they all
mention
this thing that occurred and that is
that the people of quray requested from
the prophet sallallah alai wasallam a
miracle and Allah subhanahu wa taala
split the moon one night one
evening and it was apparent to all in
Mecca that the moon had
split and they awaited Caravans to
arrive to Mecca from outside that would
have been on their way to
Mecca at night and they would have seen
this so they waited to see if anyone
else mentioned it and the Caravans that
arrived to Mecca after all mentioned
that they would wied the moon split
Muslim and non-muslim alike this is
something that is common knowledge
amongst the
companions it was common knowledge
amongst
the Allah subhanahu waala mentions this
in the opening verses ofah Al he says
subhanahu waala that which translates to
the hour has approached and the moon has
been split
and
so some have said well you know this is
such an incredible occurrence why hasn't
it been mentioned by other historians
you know we have historians in Europe we
have well at the time wasn't referred to
as Europe but that area we have
asianic
historians Indians and so forth the
Persians we don't find in their books
and in their literature mention of this
event and so some have attempted
to translate or to interpret the verse
the opening verse
of rather than it saying the hour has
approached and the moon has been
split they say no what's meant is the
hour has approached and the moon will be
split meaning on the day of
judgment and this is their sole
reasoning but this kind of
interpretation raises more questions
than it does provide answers because we
have narrations from ANB Malik we have
narrations from Abdullah abas we have
narrations from many of the companions
from many of
the and all of the scholars
of save very
few have accepted this type of
interpretation they've all said
no meaning that the moon was split and
they cite the event that
occurred in the time of the Prophet
Sall alai wasam with the PO of
qur prior to Hijra prior to his
pilgrimage to Medina his
migration and so this is not
necessarily an issue it's not unheard
of
for one area to be able to see something
that another area will not with regards
to celestial bodies
the moon eclipses and different places
in the Earth all of the time and we
don't usually see all of those
eclipses we are only privy to
eclipses of the Moon and of the Sun at
certain times when we are in the correct
angle to be able to see that so there
may be a solar eclipse that will be seen
in Europe and not seen in America
there may be solar eclipses that will be
seen in the Far East and not seen in
the Far West due to the difference in
angle when looking at the moon and the
sun and the
Optics of that and so this is not
something that is necessarily an
issue at all the fact that we don't find
this documented even though it's it's
been mentioned that some historian
in India had documented this or they
found documentation of this
event this is something that happened
at
night either
people elsewhere were at night it was
night time and they were most people are
sleeping they're
indoors except for those who
specialize in in watching the sun and
the moon or it was daytime and they
couldn't see very reasonable that this
is something that could only be seen
from the angle of the people of Mecca
at the time so this is not an issue and
the splitting of the moon is one of the
greatest Miracles that the prophet
sallallah alai wasam was ever given it
was an incredible miracle and was noted
as such by Allah subhanahu wa taala in
the Quran
he
mentions
another miracle of the Prophet sallallah
wasam that
water
was that water came forth and gushed
forth from between the prophet sallallah
alam's fingers this has been
collected by both bukari and Muslim on
the authority of
anus and
others that they were traveling once
with the prophet
sallam they were very low on water he
put his hand into a bucket that had a
little bit of water in it and Water
started to gush forth from between his
fingers
and they all
drank and made
W and took water in their you know in
their cantens or their water
skins and this is something that
occurred in the prophet Sall alam's time
another
isin
[Silence]
another is
and what he means by this is an incident
that occurred Inari and Muslim after hij
that the prophet sallallah alai
wasam it was mentioned to him that
there's a well that is dried up it's
very important well in Medina and the
prophet sallallah Ali wasallam was
brought to this well he took a mouth
full of water and spit it back into the
well and the well began to fill with
water as a miracle for the prophet
[Silence]
Sall
and no we mentions that not only water
was increased but also food food was
increased in the time of the Prophet
sallallahu alai this occurrence that
he's referring to is An Occurrence that
happened after
hij and it occurred in the battle of the
Confederates also known as the battle of
the
trench while they were digging the
trench around a portion of Medina it was
very cold out and there was almost a
famine going on in Medina they were
in great strain and food was very scarce
in Medina during that time and this is
the only occasion documented in which
the prophet sallallah alai wasam was so
hungry that he tied a stone to his belly
to try to
alleviate some of the hunger pains
and so they were digging the trench and
the prophet sallallah alai was was
digging the trench with
them tells
us that while they were digging a trench
the companions that were
digging Came Upon a
boulder their way that they couldn't
move it was too big to move and it was
impeding their
progress and so they called The Prophet
Sall alai wasallam and he came down he
took
the he took
the you know he took the digging
instrument whatever it was and he struck
it he struck this Boulder with it and it
turned to dust in front of the
companions
of course this is something that was
very necessary at the time I mean if you
can
imagine that you're digging a
trench in the middle of the bitter
cold this trench was not a small trench
it was hundreds of meters
long and meters wide as well it was
also deep and they were digging this to
make a kind of moat around a portion of
Medina in order order to help them
defend Medina better due to the lack of
numbers and the lack
of ability to to meet their enemies
equally in battle with regards to
numbers and
and equipment and
artillery and so they decided to dig
this trench around a portion of Medina
and this is something that was suggested
by Salman
was originally from Persia the Arabs
didn't fight this this wasn't known
to them to dig trenches and be in a
defensive situation this that would
continue for days or even weeks but this
is a strategy that Salman suggested
because he had seen it done successfully
in Persia so they started to dig this
moat and and they got word that all
of the Arab tribes and some of the
non-arab some of the non polytheist
tribes some of the Christians from
Hashem as well started they had agreed
to
collaborate and to attack Medina to try
to eradicate the Muslims once and for
all and so they started to dig this
trench they were very Des desate it was
a time of great poverty it was a time of
extreme
hunger because they had been more or
less cut off by
most of their allies and tribes and
forsaken they had a very shaky agreement
with the Jews of Medina to watch the
back and they are desperately digging
this trench
cold and they're hungry they're so
hungry that they're tying Stones onto
their stomachs to try to alleviate
some of the hunger pains that they
had and so they needed a
boost and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam came down and struck this
Boulder and turned it to dust this was
an incredible occurrence rejuvenated the
spirit of the companions
there an saw
this and he went back to his stepfather
Abu
tal and he said to him you know I saw
this is going on and I believe that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
very very hungry he's got a stone tied
to his
stomach and so Abu T had a small goat
very small it was not even a
yearling and it was the only goat that
he had but he didn't want to you know he
couldn't bear to leave the prophet Sall
wasallam to suffer any longer if he
could do anything about it and so he
slaughtered the goat very small goat and
of course if the people are hungry the
animals are hung hungry so the goat is
very
skinny and he
sent to the prophet s. wasam to whisper
to
him to come to his stepfather's
home because they have prepared a goat
for him a very small goat and Anis was
told strictly tell him in his ear
whisper it to him don't let anybody else
know because we don't have enough for
multiple people we have barely enough
for ourselves and him so anus did as he
was told and the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam received the invitation from
Anis and then he announced to all the
companions that were there at the
trench told everyone come with me we've
been invited to's
house was shocked he ran
ahead to Abu
tal as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is coming with over a hundred
men that haven't eaten for
days and he told Abu T he said I I did
what you said I whispered it to him and
he announced to everybody to bring them
and he's coming with everyone
one and
so they said well if that's the case
he he knows what he's doing and
so when the prophet sallallah alai
wasam
arrived
he came
in and he sat at the pot and the pot had
a cover on
it and he told everyone to get in line
and to come in and get their portion and
he served it out
himself with his
hands and everyone came in and got a
portion enough that they had
leftovers and they were all completely
they had all eaten to their fill with
leftovers and they had enough to send to
their neighbors as
well and every time someone would come
in he would cover the pot and then he
would open it back up and the food would
not be decreased at all no matter how
much he dished out to everyone this
obviously is
a miracle of Allah subhanahu wa
taala and Subhan Allah you know if
you experience something this if
you could imagine with me the
companions
you know they feel desperate they feel
hungry and all of a sudden the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
feeding over a hundred people out of
one
pot this is an incredible boost in faith
and
spirit
[Silence]
subh
Muslim
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu waala
another thing that we mentioned the
next thing
is and that is
that this narration is
in narrates to us that he heard the
prophet sallallah alam's food and meal
making saying Subhan Allah as he was
eating it this is something that
sometimes people they miss the point
when they hear these things they miss
the
point they want to understand how does
this happen this is not something that
we can understand that's the whole point
of it being miraculous if we understood
how it was done or how it happened or
the physics behind it it wouldn't be a
miracle
necessarily the idea is that the
messenger of Allah mmad s. wasam is sent
to the people and miraculous things
occur that indicate clearly the validity
of his claim to prophethood and the
validity of his message from Allah sub
as for how these things happen this is
besides the
point
[Silence]
all
can another thing
that is of the Miracles of the
Prophet
Sall is the crying or the sobbing heard
from the trunk of a
tree what is that that is that the
prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam in his
early days in Medina when he had just
migrated when the Masjid was first built
he would stand next to a the trunk
of one of the DAT palm trees that were
was in the Masjid and he would address
the companions there and he would give
his there after this the
companions one of
the
one of the companions who was a
carpenter at the behest of the Prophet
s. wasam constructed for him a
three-step
Pulpit so he started to give
his from that pulpit and the first time
he went up the pulpit to give
this or to address the companions from
the pulpit the companions
heard the date palm sobbing and the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam had to
console it sobbing why because it had
this great this great honor of being
used by the prophet sallallah
wasam in his path to Allah and then
this was taken from it
by something that was more
[Silence]
appropriate
also a stone or a boulder in Mecca was
known to the prophet sallallah wasam
that when the prophet would pass by it
it would convey a Salam to him this
narration is in
Muslim
[Silence]
Med
another incident that occurred this
narration is an authentic narration is
collected by
Abu and and others it's a well-known
narration
on the authority
of
that the prophet. wasam was invited to
eat from the from a a
shoulder shoulder of a sheep that was
cooked for him and that was his favorite
part of the sheep was the shoulder and
so this Jewish woman in Medina had
placed this poison in it and invited the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam to
eat
it so when he went to eat it
the the food itself alerted the prophet
Sall Al to its
poisoning the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam asked her why she placed the
poison in
it
[Silence]
when she was asked why did you do
this attempting
to poison the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and other companions ate with
him and they subsequently Di died as a
result he
said well I figured if you are really a
prophet it's not going to affect you and
if you are not then we would be rid of
[Silence]
you
wasam
[Silence]
oh
weak
[Silence]
this is another thing that Ani mentions
here is that a tree
was witnessed to
have come to the prophet
sallam when he called it so there was a
man who was a
magician a su s from amongst the tribes
of
qur
and he heard about the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam and they were
saying that you know he is a poet or
he's a liar or sometimes they would say
that he
was what they would
sayon meaning either that he
is he is crazy mentally ill or
maon meaning that he has some kind of
magic or spell over
him and so this man came to the prophet
s. wasam and asked
him tell me what your symptoms are I am
the most skilled
doctor in my community and what's meant
here by doctor is a a witch
doctor tell me what you are ailing from
and I will cure it I'm most skilled in
this field the prophet sallallah wasam
said shall I not show you a miracle
shall I not show you proof of my
prophethood he said of course so the
prophet sallallah alai wasam
called a tree that was in the
distance and the tree as described by
the
narrator the tree began
to carve out the Earth Earth with its
roots as it approached the prophet
sallallah
wasam and then it was SE to have
returned to its place in some narrations
it's mentioned that this man became
Muslim and others it's mentioned that
this man after seeing
this muham
[Silence]
in
some wordings of this narration it's
mention that this man accepted Islam and
other in other narrations or
other reports of this
incident it's mentioned that the man
went back to his people claiming that
the prophet s. wasam is most skilled in
Magic meaning that he rejected this
miracle that was performed for him and
wrote it off as some kind of some kind
of
Illusion and that is to show that if
Allah subhanahu waala does not guide an
individual no guidance no amount of
guidance can be bestowed upon him and
whomever Allah subhanahu
waala guides no amount of misguidance
can Allure
him
Allah